méfiez
-vous des faux prophètes
[Musique]
qui viennent à vous en vêtements de brebis
car intérieurement ce sont des
loups ravisseurs jésus est le berger qui
vous protège et je
suis son chien
[Musique]
et certains d'entre vous se sont égarés
n'est-ce pas
[Musique  ]
je suis ici pour te punir
maman es-tu beau
révérend dit qu'il est là pour te ramener d'
où il vient
j'ai vu ta mère
pourquoi tu le laisses faire ça tu l'aimes
je sais que tu es là
et je sais  vous pouvez m'entendre
vous n'avez peut-être aucun doute mais il n'y a
rien de mal avec vos oreilles
il ne s'arrêtera jamais
est-il
[Musique] les
gens pensent que ce sont les flammes qui rendent l'
enfer insupportable
ce n'est
pas c'est l'absence d'amour
je dois attendre longtemps  pour te trouver
elle appartient à l'enfer révérend
je me souviens bien d'elle
[Musique]
elle était une guerrière